our fight will continue that's the
message from these protesters in Mazar
about in pakistan-administered Kashmir a
few hundred gathered to voice their
anger against the Indian government's
decision to abolish its special status
of Kashmir the Himalayan region disputed
with Pakistan I appealed to the United
Nations to resolve this issue
immediately otherwise we will go there
to win freedom for our brothers my
appeal is to all Muslims that if we have
faith come out of your homes and stand
with us members of Pakistan's Parliament
in Islamabad voiced their anger at
India's decision to revoke autonomy and
privileges for the contested Muslim
majority region Prime Minister Imran
Khan predicted that India will crack
down even harder on the Kashmiri people
he fears ethnic cleansing and called the
ruling BJP steps in line with the racist
ideology new caledonia
exam planner Kanika gnk lectured the
manifesto though this is not a decision
the BJP have taken out of the blue it
was part of their election manifesto all
along it is in fact ingrained in their
ideology to put Hindus above all other
religions and seeks to establish a state
that represses all other religious
groups it was a heated parliamentary
session where the leader of the
opposition says that Pakistan has two
choices now either to hide or take
decisive action but people on both sides
of the line of control have heard fiery
speeches before the feeling here is of
dread and anxiety not knowing what is
happening beyond these mountains in the
indian-administered side of Kashmir
which remains cut off from the outside
world
Pakistan's military leaders say they
will go to any extent to fulfill their
obligation to the Kashmiri people but
Sonia army spokesman tweeted Pakistan
never recognized the sham Indian efforts
to legalize its occupation of Jammu and
Kashmir through article 370 or 35 a
decades ago nuclear-armed Pakistan in
India have fought multiple Wars over the
territorial dispute there are fears that
this latest coup from India could
provoke another
some urban Javed aljazeera was offer
about pakistan-administered Kashmir